ich habe hier 34 euro schnitzel ja du
aber noch kein haus noch gar kein haus
ob keine rein muss tauschen gibt es ganz
toll muss einfach nur sehr viel zucker
farmen daraus papier machen dann will
chefin der papier tausch ersten ganzen
welt voller papieren am ersten stacks
markt insider
ich weiß noch wie zuckerrohr hatte ja
pop media player
die haben eine menge talkshow media wert
solcher sprung gefunden
ich habe auch was gefunden ding ist
durch muss es überhaupt noch nach hause
finden
ob das was wird who knows
du bist echt ziemlich weit weg nennt es
ist mitternacht
ich mache mir sehr scharf oder so
gefunden
eben nicht das war ja eigentlich hier
der sinn
auf einmal findet dann nur auf alles
mögliche was viel seltener ist als
schafe die das einschlafen dass sie
echte man schmeckt stream selten kannst
dass du scharf irgendwie aus gemacht
hast oder so nein das kann man gar nicht
außerdem habe ich auch schon welche
gefunden
durch den mal ganz kurz in die fahrpläne
software media und fahren wir da so ein
bisschen zuckerrohr schafe um gefährlich
ist wenn man den game sie werden nicht
zu euch kommen wenn ihr alles vernichtet
was ihr da schon stehen habt wirklich
vernichte ja nicht ich war dass er nur
ab dass sechster wieder nach
ich dachte schon die reist also offers
ponder drei monster direkt vor mir
2 gb doch die 4,4 creed 3 3 creeper und
ein skelett du kannst ja nach der
aufnahme angucken höre dir
und einer ist direkt vom pop shop medias
haus ein treiber und ich kämpfe mit dem
hut nehmen besiegt und das noch ein
skelett das wird sich jetzt auch noch
hin
ach ich hab ja sogar wolle dich
mitnehmen können aus der festung ehrlich
aber die kettenreaktion zu sein das ich
hier ins blaue du die götter welche
götter die götter die sparc anhimmeln
und sich dann umbringen
darüber macht man keine späße der den
erwerben neues thema ja interessant
werde bei 32 minuten
die überbevölkerung der erde für
überbevölkerung von lukas wäre übrigens
mal ein cooles thema über sie reden
könntet überbevölkerung der erde und wie
das in zukunft aussehen könnte
das ist daran überbevölkerung nach den
wirkungen der ära ich meine wir haben
kein kein immenses wachstum ich meine
wir haben glaube ich nein gar nicht in
der seckenheimer chinesen zum beispiel
der welt an ihr vorbeilaufen würden wer
die schlange so lange oder wird sich
immer neu bilden weil die geburtenrate
ist hoch das heißt hier schlange
wirklich enden
das ist doch so dass in der sekunde ein
mensch stirbt und 11 menschen irgendwie
also jetzt aber ist also statistisch
statistisch stattlicher teil statistik
und christlich statistisch wiedergeboren
werden
und ich meine wenn ich mir das also
anruf wie viele gebiete es noch gibt
dies bebauen gibt auf der erde also doch
natürlich die mängel sind deutschen
verhältnismäßig zu viele
schau dir mal grafen anfang entwicklung
der bevölkerungszahlen wie das kann zu
einem graf ganz gut einfach sehen wie
das dann plötzlich sowie nach oben geht
so aber ist noch nicht mal wärmer mit
der industrialisierung haben wir nicht
her natürlich nicht alles jetzt sehr
nahe warte mal ist das jetzt auf uns
bezug auf unser leben ob wir in unserem
leben genug platz haben werden oder
allgemein auf welchen song wird uns auch
schon an das wird uns auch schon
anfangen weil ich hab das jetzt vor
allem mit der vor allem mit der
klimaveränderung und dadurch dass es
dann einfach in den weichen regionen wie
spanien so wird wie nordafrika und dass
man dort nicht mehr so gut leben kann
das heißt mehr werden und in unsere
breiten ziehen darum wird insgesamt
knapp
aber das wird immer heftiger werden und
dann wird und auch das wasser wird dann
einfach aus einer region
ich dachte das wäre darauf bezogen dass
wir wenn wir später groß sind kein platz
mehr zum leben haben werden
ich hab da setzte drastisch genommen das
ist ja nicht so dass wir kein raum mehr
haben dass wir zusammen ist es so viele
menschen auf einem fleck sind dass wir
keine luft mehr bekommen aber dass das
ein wanderer dann einfach dort in
unserer das einfach noch mehr
einwanderer zu uns kommen einfach weil
es bei denen man das weil man bei den
nicht mehr leben kann und das wird ein
riesen problem sein dass wir unser leben
total beeinflussen denke ich mal nicht
in 30 40 jahren aussehen wird
das wird unser leben total beeinflussen
jedoch nicht in den nächsten 100 jahren
die finanz ist nicht nur glaube ich
nicht egal was in den nächsten 100
jahren wird das auch nicht passieren
darum macht sowas schauten sich einige
handwerker jetzt stimmt wie der kampf
ums wasser knapp werden
genau und das wird die leute zu bringen
in diesen auch zum beispiel nach
mitteleuropa noch viel stärker zu kommen
als jetzt weißt du allein die leute ist
ganz aus schwarzafrika also daraus von
afrika das heißt so schwarz ist heißt so
fasst das ist der bereich wunder der
saal und das ist der begriff der begriff
leitet sich der begriff der bereich
unter der sahara als es nicht südafrika
ganz unten und ist wirklich spannend
afrique das heißt du nie gehört new york
wenn wir werden wir neu ein bisschen
aber doch können wir mal in der
wikipedia schauen oder was weiß ich
irgendwo das sind ganz ruhig ich habe
nachher schwarzafrika und einfach die
leute die dort von dort kommen die haben
einfach keine lebensgrundlage mehr dort
und darum werden dann ziehen die dann
nach europa und die werden dann über
schleuser während jan in den nach
marokko gebracht und ähnliche länder und
dann mit irgendwelchen vollgestopften
schiffen die dann teilweise auch
kennzeichnen wie sie an alle elendig
daher verrecken muss man schon sagen
weil wir das schiff untergeht die
schleuser spielen die unter deck einen
gehen sie einfach unter aber erst vor
wenigen tagen ist mal wieder so ein fall
für das lasche boerse.com
dafür brauche ich kein erdkunde leider
steht unser erdkunde unterricht auch
sehr nichts sagen in sachen das besteht
einfach daraus mit offenen augen durch
die welt zu gehen und auch mal
nachrichten zu lesen hören zu
konsumieren
ich hab das ohne scheiß ich guck jeden
tag nachrichten und das habe ich nie
mitbekommen dass irgendwie so was gesagt
wurde die ja jetzt ist dort und dort
wieder ein boot voller einwanderer
untergegangen und so weiter ich kanns ja
wenn du willst gleich mal nachschauen wo
ich sagen das war
aber ich denke das wird uns massiv
beeinflussen aber wirklich massiv ja in
welchem zeitraum 30 40 jahre also dann
wenn wir mitten im leben stehen oder was
jetzt mit einem leben das wird aber es
wird auch ein schon in 20 jahren wird
das schon fast 1 wird auf jeden fall
unser leben noch
seit meine angepasst es sollte jetzt
nicht abwertend klingen ja aber ich
wollte mal so ausdrücken weil sonst
lacht er nett schade da kann ich hab da
richtig drauf gemacht auf einmal bewegen
die sich nie war das was das dann doch
zur selben zeit
lukas ist die mehrzahl von rollmops
arena wo bleibt eigentlich nacht ich
traue mich nicht
es ist immer noch da hinten haha nein
wusstet ihr schon dass ich hunde nicht
vor krieg und verteidigen
leider das was dich nicht oder dich vor
kriegt man verteidigen dass sie dich
nicht vortrieb an verteidigen
das wusste ich nicht
ich weiß gar nicht wie ich das khat
bauen soll
ja ich kenne den tempel baute ihn so
halpap dazu noch ruine
jetzt kommt wieder ein superlativ okaka
auf ja ich kann nicht ich habe auch noch
nie gesagt dass bauen kann und ich kann
sie auch einfach nicht hallo ich bin
gerade am üben beim bauen
wer dort weniger so allgemein so nach
einem jahr minecraft creative mode
wieder besser so lanka dialogs oben geht
mir creative mode gibt mehr gibt's
endlich wieder steinmauern erledigt
jetzt da gibt es in der prärie dies
stimmt snapshot gibt's die halle ist er
so viel wolle nehme ich alles mit beim
häuten keine schere ich kann meine baum
eine schere bauen ja traf zusammen
packen kann ich mir das mein ich dachte
ich kann das jetzt so schön unterstützen
aber nicht echt gern so eine steinmauer
jetzt muss er hier mit auskommen ist
okay dass ich alles kaputt meine ja dann
haben wir immer hin wollte auch wenn
immer noch keine schafe haben irgendwo
wo man den fluss runter gelaufen ist da
könnten wir hier sein weil sie da waren
sich auf jeden fall ich weiß nicht mehr
genau wo man gestorben bin welcher fluss
der fluss der werkstatt media house ist
dabei im sportshop media aus wie haben
die das noch mal getauft notebook pda
aus das haus ich habe hier 34 euro
schnitzel ja du aber noch kein haus noch
gar kein haus ist vielleicht ein
bisschen anfang ja außer dass da hinten
hallo das teilten sie am ende keiner aus
als ihr denkt man schon habt ihr gerade
ein holz geklaut war ich manchmal noch
ressourcen schnorren bei euch aber
ansonsten okay ich komme jetzt nach
hause ich habe nicht mal mensch gezeigt
schnell komplett eisen spitze gebracht
sogar ist immer noch da hinten rum
naja wer mehr zeit als vier parks oder
familie so minister relativ entspannt
eigentlich stadt kann man noch mehr
aufnehmen
am anfang muss man genau irgendwann
anfangen fertig werden na ja ich habe
schon alles geplant ich muss erstmal nur
richtig ressourcen sammeln könnte
zutritt sammeln schmeißt mir alles holz
zu was ihr habt am besten auch dunkles
holz
ich muss selber sammeln ich habe aber
das holz aber das brauche ich gleich
selber
hier wird dir nichts geschenkt nennen
muss alles selber machen
siehst du mal schon die ganze zeit am
abholzen
den wollen wir gleich mal auf die suche
nach schaffen gehen
ich bin ja schon in search for dynamics
eine waffe habe ich sie auch dauernd
kühe und andere es geht hier aber
wirklich gar keine schafe so im sinne
von kein war musste ein anderes warum
ich glaube wir diese stätten ist glaube
ich ein bisschen besser für schafe ja da
sind wir auch eine stattliche scharf ich
glaube ich in den wald rein müssen ein
bisschen auf die koordinaten schauen
aber ich glaube ich laufe gerade sogar
relativ richtig zurück die höheren die
runde nicht mehr auf nicht schlafe ich
habe eine schwere baumschere ja weil ich
endlich sind sie sind in der nähe von
vom dings nett aha da ja genau
wenn eine rolle o-ton ihre droht
vielmehr seals stimmen
aber ich hab ich nicht daher zu locken
bis nach hause das in 800 blöcke durch
betont leider sehe ich viel acht recht
krass egal ob du hast ja hause locken
wir verbauen wir dann wolle du musst
einfach die worte mitnehmen die sechs
wolle habe ich jetzt wow erreicht dass
er oder ich konnte entgegen
mit beat dann mache ich das und ich habe
auch gut aber ich hab dir nicht trotzdem
ich nach hause zurück ich hab auch ried
der aber wenn wir zwei sind geht das
vielleicht schneller also dann kann der
eine fünf neben der andere fünf oder so
wie viel schlaf machst du 23 43
sag mal wurde ungefähr bis 700 satte 130
und 730 130 und 730 reserve klappt ja
ich hab da so ein automatischen sinn
einfach immer ab zur fernseh im tempel
mit auch etwas für nicht kunden jetzt
ein bisschen die welt irgendwann mach
ich mir noch eine karte und dann weiß
man erst mal weiterhin zu hause bin
das ist dann auch langsamer wieder eine
zweite den ist noch ein schaf smart
village bei der show läuft auch leute
ist das schön hauses gefangen über
gagfah sieht man schon ganz stylisch aus
cribari war mitten am tag zum 4
batak bin voll weit gesprungen
du bist wenn du hinten fehler weil die
bewegen sich doch nicht aber das doch
kein fehler bist du tot
bitte bitte aber der eine ist explodiert
ich glaube erst mal weiter richtung
richtung home sweet home und dann hoffe
ich mal dass mir noch welche schaffen
schon wieder schafe wird so enders
nirgendwo bei uns in der nähe nur so
weit weg überall schafe im erstmal bild
damit ich mir schon alles von denen erst
nicht wieso sind hier so viele
unternehmen irgendwo hat die teile
könnten auch mal mitnehmen
die kann ja sogar 34 schnitzel die
stammt von einer einzigen schweineherde
die ich gefunden habe übrigens run fun
factory schafe trotzdem versucht es
jetzt einmal aber ich glaube chefs man
bis nach hause zu leiten
weil er einfach zu dumm sind warum
können nicht wie twitter folgen oder
eisen sind so doof wer die schafe mutter
ja oder kühe also eine hunde hören nicht
mehr so nicht komischer weise umgesetzt
mit wiederkommen wenn ich mach mich kein
bock mehr wohl vorher wohl keinen bock
mehr
was waren aber die iks koordinate die
iks koordinate war 100 km laufen ist
aber gar nicht so immens weit weg 700
bin ich bei z540 unser haus ist bei 202
springer hier sind viele schafe waren
sie echt brite auch ja warte ich nicht
einfach mal wissen wollte mit aber die
waffenruhe die alle erst dann sehen wir
bisher irgendwie man die falsche
richtung gelaufen also reden wir mal
drei wolle stückchen mit wenn ca bisher
gibt jedes schafft nur ein wolle obwohl
ich eine schere an das muskels warten
wir was wollen